bonjour à tous et bienvenue dans ce set
8 l'actu 7,8 la cub qui commence tout de
suite avec l'image du jour ce matin à
l'appel des syndicats snes fsu les
étaient une trentaine d'agents
d'établissements d'éducation prioritaire
à se réunir devant la direction des
services de l'éducation nationale à
guyancourt enseignants et conseillers
principaux d'éducation protestent contre
le manque de moyens alloués pour la
prochaine rentrée 2014
il réclame aujourd'hui plus d'effectifs
pour accueillir dans de meilleures
conditions le nombre croissant d'élèves
qui arrive en zep
chaque année des élèves qui ont besoin
d'attention comme nous l'expliquent ward
à beynac couche duncan auch pardon ce
cpe au collège paul cézanne de mantes la
jolie
on a toujours fait le choix en fait au
niveau de la répartition de notre
dotation de garder des effectifs
raisonnables pour pouvoir travailler
bah petit effectif en classe c ça
pénalise notamment les dédoublements
notamment dans certaines matières comme
les langues ou d'autres disciplines qui
nécessiterait d'être des doublés pour
pouvoir justement résorber les
difficultés scolaires de nos élèves plus
de dédoublement certainement plus
d'enseignants c'est ce qu'on souhaite
aussi pouvoir maintenir des équipes
stables avoir des supports pour avoir de
réel équipée pour faire un vrai travail
de concertation
parce que notre collège accueille quand
même 90% de catégories
socioprofessionnelles défavorisées et
j'ajoute que cette journée d'action se
poursuivent et cet après midi par une
manifestation à paris en direction du
ministère de l'éducation nationale
dès 14 heures l'université de versailles
saint quentin tiendra son conseil
d'administration demain vendredi pour
voter ou non le budget 2014
pour rappel lui est lu vs qu affiche un
déficit de plus de 5 millions d'euros
un premier conseil d'administration
s'était tenu il ya tout juste un mois
mais la présence de l'université avait
la présidence de l'université avait
présenté un budget en déficit ce qui est
contraire aux règles édictées par le
ministère
la présidence avait alors un mois pour
représenter un nouveau budget cette fois
en équilibre l'intersyndicale qui
regroupe ans
saignant étudiants et personnels se
regroupera demain à 13h30 devant la
direction de l'université à versailles
marine le pen en soutien au candidat
tête de liste front national dans le
département un déplacement remarqué ce
mercredi soir aux chaînés 1 il faut dire
qu'en 2008 aucune liste frontiste
n'avait été déposée pour leurs 23
candidats se sont annoncées et 9 liste
serait déjà bouclé c'est inespéré
confesse même le président départemental
du front national catherine mulato et
jonathan vilma n'en ambiance détendue et
tout sourire ce mercredi soir au chalet
avec la venue de la leader du front
national une marine le pen enthousiaste
en 2008 aux dernières municipales il n'y
avait eu aucune liste fn dans le
département est aujourd'hui 23 listes
sont annoncés il ya eu un effort
absolument spectaculaire puisque avait 0
10 l'an 2008
par conséquent arriver à avoir 23 tête
de liste avec déjà un grand nombre de
ces dix qui sont d'ores et déjà bouclé
cette un très bel effort d'implantation
locale c'est une priorité pour le front
national
c'est énorme c'est complètement et
d'espérer dans les yvelines on a
exactement à 100% on calque notre
politique sur celle de marine le pen et
ça les gens leur sang en tout ces 23
listes représentent 600 colistiers 600
personnes qui ont donc fait le choix de
porter les couleurs du rassemblement
bleu marine pour le département philippe
chevrier espère une trentaine d'élus
grâce notamment à la présence de
candidats lors de triangulaires car pas
question d'union pour un éventuel second
tour
nous nous maintiendrons bien sûr au
second tour car
nous voulons absolument porter la voix
du bon sens dans les conseils municipaux
et il nous apparaît que en matière de
bon sens l'ump le ps
ont quand même énormément de retard sur
notre secteur des candidats se sont
déclarés à montigny plaisir les
clayes-sous-bois elancourt reste a
clôturé les listes sur les 23 annoncés 9
serait bouclée les autres seraient
partiellement constitué
impossible de savoir lesquels on soit
simeoni à versailles et philippe
chevrier à rambouillet e déposeront bien
la liste en préfecture d'ici la fin de
semaine et toujours dans le cadre des
élections sachez que dès aujourd'hui tv
fil 78 vous propose un site internet
dédié aux municipales 2014
vous pourrez retrouver les reportages de
la rédaction consacré à ces élections
les entretiens et les débats menés entre
candidats une rubrique carnet de
campagne vous permettent également de
suivre l'actualité des candidats par
ville est toujours dans le cadre des
élections à 20 heures ce jeudi diffusion
du premier débat autour de la commune de
voisins-le-bretonneux dimanche 16
février 23e édition du semi-marathon des
lions au départ de bullion dans la forêt
de rambouillet à mes côtés pour en
parler catherine piller directrice de
l'hôpital de pédiatrie et de rééducation
de bullion bonjour catherine et jacques
le lostec président du lions club des
essarts le roi et directeur de la course
depuis 20 ans bonjour jacques bonsoir
déjà un mot sur la course jacques je ne
demande pas de galanterie mais je vais
commencer par jacques je le disais un
semi marathon de 21,1 km une course très
prisé et qui je crois se déroule sur un
site particulièrement agréable dans la
forêt de rambouillet oui leur
effectivement cette course a lieu
essentiellement sur de la route
goudronnée à travers la forêt et entre
les communes donc 2
lyon clairefontaine la salle déborde
c'est un semi marathon qui est très
prisé parce qu'il s'effectue dans les
premiers de la saison donc un bon
entraînement le parcours et le dénivelé
qui sont intéressants et par ailleurs
aussi sûrement le fait qu'on le limit
quantitativement mais pas
qualitativement on accepte que 13 cents
coureurs compte tenu des infrastructures
locales
alors justement c'est ça qui me l'a
demandé excusez-moi de vous couper 1200
coureurs sont attendus mais je crois que
chaque année il y en a un petit peu plus
combien au total et est ce qu il reste
encore des places pour s'inscrire
alors actuellement on est on frise les
13 cents mais nous savons qu'il ya
toujours quelques défections entre 5 et
10%
donc nous avons quand même maintenu des
inscriptions possibles sur place avec
tous les aléas que ça comporte
évidemment puisque le pourcentage est
défection n'est pas connue avant qu'elle
ne soit effective quoi mais on espère
bien tout de même même s'il fallait
déborder un peu mais nous avons tout de
même prévu des dossards supplémentaires
de manière à ne pas renvoyer trop de
coureurs quand même donc même s'il y en
avait 13 120 je crois que il y en aurait
trait semble bon alors justement pour ça
sert comment fait-on combien ça coûte et
des conditions à réunir pour s'inscrire
le site déjà sur la forêt de rangoon à
la hâte il y avait deux trois
possibilités il y avait une possibilité
qui était s'inscrire sur internet
sportif.com le sportif points comme ça
nous l'avons arrêté il ya quatre cinq
jours quand on a vu qu'on est passé déjà
les doux 112-120 deuxième possibilité
nous sommes en partenariat avec les
nouvelles de versailles qui donc est dit
le bulletin dans l'eure
journaux donc deuxième possibilité puis
la troisième possibilité qui est tout de
même au travers des sites lui en ce
plaisir qui permet de tirer bulletin de
s'inscrire
donc il y avait trois possibilités
aujourd'hui on n'a plus aucune puisqu'on
a stoppé tous là évidemment puisque on
est rendu au terme
combien ça coûte l'inscription
l'inscription ses 12 euros et 14 euros
pour ceux qui viendront sur place
d'accord ça ces inscriptions il faut le
dire ça rapporte des fonds des fonds qui
seront reversés à l'hôpital pédiatrique
et de rééducation de bullion catherine à
quoi concrètement vont servir ces fonds
récoltés alors il ya quand même 23 ans
que le lion's-club se mobilisent
activement pour organiser ce semi
marathon et les fonds il faut le savoir
sont intégralement reversés pour
l'hôpital de bullion avec déduction bien
entendu de tout ce qui a trait la
logistique et je peux vous dire que j'en
ce club s'attache à bien prendre soin
des des coureurs et donc nous en fait
les fonds sont utilisés pour améliorer
la qualité de vie des patients ce à quoi
nous tenons beaucoup à l'hôpital de
bullion dont ce sont des enfants qui
sont là sur de très longue durée pour
des maladies rares des cancers des
maladies chroniques et on essaie de
faire en sorte que ces enfants et des
journées qui pourrait être proche de
celle qu'ils auraient leur domicile ils
vont à l'école il ya une école in situ
il y a une piscine une balnéothérapie un
mur d'escaladé
je fais allusion mur d escalade que vous
avez financé il ya quelques années ça
peut être un minibus
adapté pour des polyhandicapés sévère de
manière à pouvoir les emmener voir un
parc un parc avec des animaux les
promener enfin leur permettre voilà le
but est toujours d'améliorer la
condition les conditions de vie de
l'enfant etc d'enfants à fait normaux
comme comme tous les ans oui mais voilà
avec des activités qui ont été financés
au fil au fil des années oui c'est
centre est vraiment sur le loisir
alors je pense qu'il ya des enfants qui
vont aussi participer à la course
on va le voir on va le voir en photo
mais via des joëlettes ou alors
expliquez nous un peu le principe
alors je ne connaissais pas les
joëlettes effet grâce à un éducateur
spécialisé qui travaille à bullion qui
nous a fait cette proposition
extraordinaire parce que lui-même
participé au marathon de paris avec les
sapeurs pour les photos justement là et
donc le principe c'est un peu un
fauteuil roulant mais en fait qui n'a
pas les cas trop habituel avec 4,2 de
personnes qui tueur devant et deux plats
bio jardin derrière qui est activée ce
qui permet à l'enfant polyhandicapé
d'avoir le sentiment de participer à un
événement aussi important qu'un semi
marathon je crois qu'il aura cinq
enfants ça voulait qu'ils vont
participer et des enfants qui vont aussi
remettre les coupes aux vainqueurs
alors ça nous y tenons beaucoup l'année
dernière c'était extrêmement émouvant et
très sympathique puisque on ne pouvait
pas capter le public je pense ne pouvait
même pas réalisé la lourdeur des
pathologies qu'avaient les enfants qui
étaient sur la scène
mais la fierté de ses enfants enfin y
avait par exemple un enfant un grand
brûlé
quand je parle de grands brûlés ça veut
dire quasiment de la tête aux pieds qui
a eu le courage et qui était très fier
du cookie qui avait une autre image de
lui-même en revêtant la coupe de celui
qui est arrivé en tête qui a conclu
marathon avec ses touches et valorisant
pour
que pour les les coureurs en tout cas
bravo pour cette initiative ce semi
marathon donc au profit de l'hôpital des
enfants
je crois qu'à d'autres projets qui sont
prévues on en parlera à notre phase
qu'on manque de temps mais maisons
durables pour les familles pour
accueillir les familles ou des enfants
qui sont hospitalisés on en reparlera
sur tv fil 78 très rapidement et on
enchaîne avec le reste de l'actualité
merci beaucoup en tout cas ce que d'être
venu sur ce plateau pour parler de cette
initiative et bravo à vous merci le
reste de l'actualité donc avec l'afpa
qui ouvrait aujourd'hui la porte de ces
centres de formation partout en france
pour ceux qui ne la connaissent pas
encore il s'agit d'une association qui
propose des formations pour adultes
nous nous sommes rendus à elancourt un
site spécialisé dans le tertiaire
administratif
malgré la crise des débouchés existent
encore claire cambier et étienne dongle
une journée pour changer de vie c'est ce
que proposait aujourd'hui lave pas un
organisme de formation pour adultes
entendez par là changer de vie
professionnelle partout en france les
différents centres de cette association
ont ouvert leurs portes comme ici à
elancourt
car en pleine période de crise
économique et de hausse du chômage
on compterait encore en france trois
cent mille emplois non pourvus
quels secteurs recrutent quelles
formations sont disponibles sous quelles
conditions
autant de questions auxquelles dalila et
les autres visiteurs chercher des
réponses
cette mère de famille a arrêté de
travailler pour élever ses enfants
aujourd'hui elle peine à retrouver un
emploi elle souhaiterait intégrer ici
une formation de secrétaire assistante
je reste dans ma branche
initial mais par contre reprendre une
formation pour pouvoir être plus
performantes en informatique
l'association a repéré très secteurs
d'activité sous tension de l'industrie
aéronautique et spatiale à l'économie
numérique en passant par l'hôtellerie
l'idée est donc d'aiguiller les
demandeurs d'emploi 70 % du public de
l'afpa pour qu'il réponde aux demandes
des entreprises est la valeur ajoutée en
fait des formations afpa
c'est effectivement l'insertion nos
stagiaires c'est le fait que six à sept
stagiaires sur dix soit réintégrée dans
le monde professionnel
l'utilité sociale de l'afpa et le ch'ti
volant 80% de la formation et pratique
ici par exemple un plateau technique
recréer un domicile et permet de
s'entraîner au métier d'assistant de vie
en conditions réelles en ile de france
on compte c'est citaf pas ouvert à tous
certaines formations peuvent être
rémunérés et on reste sur le thème de
l'économie avec ce soir votre fille les
corps présentés par claire cambier
demain le 7-8 l'aktu sera présenté par
anthony rech passé une excellente soirée
sur tv fil 78